hello so I put my first line up early so
that all might our talk and all the
notebooks that I'm gonna go through are
actually at this get site so you can
just go there and you and github nicely
renders them through its auto enviar now
in fact that I'm showing them now so I
will put this up and it's also going to
be at the end so you can if you didn't
get them now you can look at it later
alright let's go here okay Who am I so
I'm a former quant I work a continuum
now on various projects interesting
enough that's actually provides a lot of
fodder for thinking about like various
problems that you know companies have
and how they go about solving them and
invariably they go about solving the
wrong way but I try to help them in and
in fact a lot of these ideas got
propagated back in depend as as well as
a bunch of other open source projects
I've been working on Penn is for I've
been contributing panis for it for five
or six years and I've been a core
committer for movie the last three or
four years and I've been maintaining it
actually for last couple years all right
next okay so in general what do we care
about when we're writing code so we care
about the feature set if we didn't have
features we wouldn't have code basically
we want the software to do something
useful of course along with these
features we want things like you know we
want to have readable code we want to
have a testable code documented code and
want to be able to have other people
actually maintain it so pandas helps
with this a teeny bit mainly with the
readability actually you can basically
do a lot and it's just a few lines of
code which is which is great however
there's lots of constraints when you're
writing code how long does it take to
write the code and of course what seems
to be everybody cares about how long
does it take to run further you know
people care about things like resource
utilization maybe how much space does it
take for the hard drive to use it or how
much memory spaces you use these are all
important things I'm not gonna talk
about anything today except for the
runtime and the resource utilization
mainly things about memory
that's okay okay so what drives pen is
this is just gonna be a quick peek into
internals so you can understand how
things work a little bit and then you
can understand where performance come
somewhere does not come from actually so
pandas is basically a superset or is
basically uses numpy as a back end okay
and I'll get to this in the second one I
discuss the other backends that we use
so the principle is we have d-type
segregation and this leads to a block
memory layout so in other words i'm
going to show you my first thing here so
let's take a typical loops up here so
take a typical data frame every
student's okay you make a data frame
with a couple of different D types in it
and you have a pretty data frame now
you'll notice that you have your
different D types and there this is just
printing them out in the order that i
inputted them however if you look under
the under the hood sort of raised the
skirt a little bit you'll see that
actually this creates what's called call
blocks and these are all happen to be
there all two-dimensional blocks in this
case and the only one that's interesting
is the float block here this is actually
it's comprised of both the B and E
columns and so they're aggregated their
consolidated is what I call them so each
different view type is represented as a
block and these are all numpy raised
whereas if you have different even if
you have different columns of the same
d-type they'll bactrim you smooshed
together so this leads to an interesting
performance implication number one it
allows you to fast row aggregations ok
this was one of the original use cases
for pandas is you can take your table
and you can go really fast why because
using dump I under the hood great
however this actually leads to what sort
of a problem if I want to continuously
insert columns now I'm not gonna say you
should do this in fact I'll say this is
on my don'ts list if you start adding
columns to this what happens is pinned
as well so called consolidate them so
basically this involves a copy ok so
this is something you shouldn't do
and I will get to that in a second okay
all right so these different block types
are you so this is a nice little picture
it looks like a d-type hierarchy because
that's exactly what it is these
represent all the different types that
pandas can store at the moment the
yellow ones are so-called concrete types
as other the little green ones over
there I'm not going to go into this in
detail this if you think about it this
follows the pant the numpy d-type
hierarchy as well as the Python v-type I
reckon these are some actual future
ideas things that we're going to add
different ways of storing data so in
other words you can basically store data
and if we have a block to represent it
we can make it very efficient so here's
an example everybody knows you know feat
cons are quite efficient pandas that's
that's true however date times if you
have a time zone attached are not
efficient at all why because the
representatives an object d-type and as
it already knows numpy just represents
object essentially it's a pointer to a
Python object so you can't represent
these as base scalar types okay however
once i do that block then we'll be able
to do this okay so essentially you'll be
able to represent the data in a very
efficient form and work with it but it
will be we're going to sort of trick
numpy and we're going to say okay let's
represent our data this way is very
efficient datetime blocks but we'll have
a little attribute for time's up so this
has not done yet this is why it's in
great out other other things that are on
the road map is interred ranae and I
nobody likes to have this this will
hopefully happen soon we need some
support from some other libraries to do
this all right yes we will talk about
string handling in depth in a little bit
okay because that's important okay oops
did I go when I go here it to let me sit
okay so
I said before that pandas uses a numpy
as a computational computational back
end it uses it as a storage back end
okay but it also uses as a computational
back end in other words when you do some
what do we do we actually have a some
believe it or not but we almost always
will out we will delegate back to none
tie to actually do the operation and
there's some cases we won't do that and
I'll go through them so let me give you
a little slide here this is a picture I
did a while back for the so called PI
data ecosystem note I left out simp I
accidentally and I also left that number
which so these in blue here are the so
called computational back ends of pandas
numpy obviously is the big one here we
are going to talk briefly about
bottleneck and num express and these are
what I call highly recommended pensions
in other words they're not required but
you should really install them because
you get a lot of stuff for free so I put
this one yes okay so note in my
notebooks i usually i usually do some
stuff i like set options max row just
you know not display to me rose okay so
what does them express it's just an open
source library that basically takes
advantage of it basically translates a
string let expression into its own
internal abstract tree execute it and it
can can beaten up in a lot of situations
why because it tries not to use
temporaries okay it will just simply
evaluate the expression it'll it'll take
vectorized expressions I'll value them
it kind of like a you thump does but it
will do it without all the intermediate
steps that numba does great it can also
take advantage of multi-core and we'll
talk about that at the very end but the
point is if you have an expression this
actually is a very fairly large
expression here we're doing a boolean
operation and I will get to this in one
second but the first thing I always do
is assert that my two comparisons are
correct in other words they're equal to
each other because there's no point
comparison comparing things that do
different things and this is one of my
pet peeves and we'll go over this as
well but suffice to say these are these
give equal results here's the two time
it's this is a when I say in Python
this is just simply what I call singular
evaluation if you actually worked up the
abstract tree here this is actually
three operations here so we have you
know DF 1 is greater than D F to put it
in temporary we have D F 3 greater than
a fork put them in temporary and then do
that result against do have three
operations here number expressed and do
all at once great speed up awesome this
is done automatically for you basically
every expression actually is first tried
i'm not expression on everyone but if
it's d-type compatible it just hits num
express first you don't have to do
anything keep in mind this only really
works for things like floats in schools
it has to be a seed representable
strings we do not count certain daytime
operations actually do count because we
do some internal translations okay the
other library that we use internally
again it's a highly recommended
dependency is bottom line again this
will be used if it's installed so
install it it's basically for free in
effect it does sort of what num Express
does on a vectorized level it does this
how much well I shouldn't say on a scale
a level it has very fast and very
specific functions to do things as
simple as some or nan some and it does
it faster than numpy how does it do that
well it's very tight customized code
that has been exposed to python and it
selects the exact routine for this shape
that ND type you're passing it ok so
it'll think of it as like a like fuse
type everything and it picks exactly
what you need is very fast so here's
some comparisons and in this case I
actually have to physically turn off
bottleneck to show you the result
because otherwise it will be used on a
plate so you can get some modest speed
up and of course your mileage will vary
on various types of data sets okay next
okay the last thing that drives the last
two things that drive pandas in Turtles
we siphon for a lot of the internal
computations namely the most prevalent
of being groupwise this is all pure
scythe on and it just comes with pandas
makes things fast we also have a hash
table implementation that drives a lot
of the indexing
and this I'll show you a little teeny
bit later all right next okay so how do
we make pandas perform aside from the
readings book have correct code then you
want to profile and compare it so these
are very important steps and then rule
number three is refer back to rules
numbers one because this is an iterative
process you basically chain make a
change in something and you're like oh I
really because I can't even tell where
good performance comes to me I can't
sometimes but I always always always
profile and we'll just almost keep
hitting this that you want to have
correct code and then you want a profile
and then iterate okay when you do
comparisons it's very important to
compare the same exact things because
you know sometimes I've seen a lot of
people will compare you know Oh numpy
indexing operations are faster than
pandas like that's obvious they are
because they're doing a very specialized
thing whereas pandas tries to do a lot
of inference a lot of magic on top of
this so these are completely non
comparable people try to compare them
and they do and they're wrong okay so
this is my I like this quote that's by
donald knuth basically people try to
optimize the wrong things they try to
optimize before they even start again
we're going to stress that you should
profile a code okay these are all just
sort of general things now we're going
to actually get into some specifics of
how to make pandas fast okay first thing
is so if you have two algorithms pandas
can't help pandas reduces the the
coefficient in front of your algorithm
whatever algorithm you choose it'll
reduce the coefficient let's hope you
hope to do that but if you have an N log
n algorithm and an order an algorithm
you just use the order N 1 it's not
going to help there are some things to
note though so here's a simple example
I'm taking data from I wanna know the
top five values in the bottom five
values and naively we might sort it
pandas actually comes bundled with in an
end smallest and largest these do in
effect an order and it's not sort it's
not even
partial sort you can do that too but
these just scan and get results so again
I always try to compare things and make
sure we get same result and you can see
in this particular case you actually get
a quite a large speed up by doing this
again your mileage may vary if you're
using a small frame or a small series
this may not make any difference maybe
it's slower there's more function calls
here ok now here's actually something
that was improved on numpy so pandas has
a set of hash table implementation of
for various uses one use is unique
actually panis actually can really beat
the pants off numpy with the further
property uniques are actually done in
the same order as they are represented
not by sort that's why so not that
useful in my opinion so I almost always
use PD unique ok all right next ok I'm
going to talk about idioms so if there's
an idiom that you can use use it let's
close these as I don't need them anymore
ok so these are two I'll say easy idioms
that are pretty useful so people do a
lot of group buys this is the concept of
in fact this is actually the docs like
this where you basically will say you'll
normalize a group basically I want to do
like a z-score type of thing on a group
you can actually unwrap this so you can
use transformational operations where
you basically do the same exact thing
but you do this sort of an a I'm not
gonna say a vectorized way but what
happens is some functions that arm
there's a certain subset of functions
that are that are already sized there
was like mean standard deviation things
like that they're very fast so we can
use them and this means this is going
right to the scythe on functions if you
use apply it can be very fast but it's
not possible at the moment to decompose
this UDF this user-defined function
you're passing so this is in effect done
almost in Python space that's why it's
much slower so if you can you can unwrap
your group ice and in this case I'll
stress in this case we get a pretty good
speed up now the case i'm giving you
here is I think we have would have a
million elements here and I have oh
sorry up here and I have 10,000 groups
I'll do another case where I only have a
hundred groups it doesn't help much why
because there's overhead with doing some
of these operations and you know again
in your mileage may vary another simple
idiom is if then I have seen this so
much we'll talk about apply in depth in
a few minutes but this is just painfully
slow it's it's you're basically doing a
loop here anytime you're doing apply
you're more or less doing a loop think
about that and you're in Python space
almost the entire time so there are our
built-ins where to do exactly the same
thing and you can get quite a nice speed
up doing this okay all right going back
to my slides so again I'm going to
iterate reiterate you should use the
built-ins and vectorization as much as
possible you just always think
factorizations the same with numpy
always think vectorization first so I'm
going to show you some specific code
here let's hear ok so I'm going to do
basically a bunch of different
computations using various methods and
you'll see I'll explain why some are
faster than others so we're doing almost
a trivial computation here we're taking
a one-column multiplying by a scalar
adding another column and then we're
adding 12 and then we were doing a
reduction operation we're going to some
okay here's the pandas code numpy code
looks pretty similar i'm using this dot
values and i'll go in through that in a
few minutes in effect a dot values on a
series will just give you back the numpy
ray we're going to try the same exact
thing using num num express directly
again you have to actually use a string
expression here and we'll do it using
bottleneck further we're going to use an
actual site on routine to do the same
exact calculation and we're going to use
a number routine to do the same exact
calculation one thing to note numpy
raise a sorry sight on and number both
take numpy raised directly they don't
operate on series or data frames
directly at the moment they might in the
future so I'm wrapping these little
function just to just return actual i'm
not going to net here i will do that in
another example i'm calling with a
function here what I'm doing to stick
just to make it even performance again
i'm i'm doing an assert effectively here
that these are all equal values to some
precision so results numpy you get you
know decent performance pandas you
actually get slightly better performance
the reason is this actually is going out
to bottleneck interesting enough now I'm
express itself you get quite good
performance using bottleneck itself is
not great in this case or it's pretty
pretty similar and I said before we're
for this expression here we're actually
going out to bottom like we don't
actually do the use the bottleneck this
most of if you think about it most of
this actually is a numpy operation here
so it's sort of so that the test i'm
doing a bottleneck is actually a
combination so it's not a good test of
the bottom line but i just stuck in
there and of course if you look at the
bottom two numbers a custom site on a
routine and a custom number we can
actually beat the pants off of all this
well i'll be like okay we should just
write everything in that well no because
you know for the most part this is
pretty it's much nicer to write this
kind of expression it just is and you
know when you have a critical part of
the code okay great drop in this iphone
or drop into the number fantastic it'll
work okay my next I'm going to also give
you a just a very brief next notebook
here this is very similar the last one
except i'm doing a specific example here
this is something that right now is just
basically impossible to do in pandas
because i'm so i'm going to model a
recurrence relationship and i'm going to
impact on my model particular one
this is e WMA exponentially weighted
moving average and I'll the reason I'm
doing this very specific one is because
pandas actually has an implementation of
this it's not completely general though
it's very specific it takes like one
parameter however there's lots of people
who want to do something very general
they want to write their own recurrence
relationship and right now in pan is
this you cannot do this it's you can
that'll be painfully slow so I'm going
to go to a Python implementation here
and in this case I actually I'm also
have a scythe on implementation right
here and I'm doing what I said I was
good to before which is I'm wrapping
these things so they look like the same
exact object coming out i'm wrapping
them in this series so i'm passing an
umpire rays and then i'm wrapping them
in a series to come out okay i'm doing
the same thing here I'm just simply
calling the pan is routine pde WMA okay
I'm doing the same thing with number and
you'll notice the code the scythe on
code and the number code is very much
like the Python code know this is sort
of a well-known phenomenon I think at
this point and this is this is the
beauty you can just literally copy and
paste your code stick a decorator on it
and you number output is great you have
to be really careful though the one
problem you're gonna find with either
number or scythe on is that if you try
to pass in a series number one it won't
work with it with site on it'll actually
work with numba the problem is that i've
seen a lot of people they go and they
try to index into this that is a problem
at the moment will simply not work
you'll but you'll be pushed back into
python mode so you tend to be really
cognizant what you are doing really work
solely with numpy raise you can pass in
the index if you want and the values now
this may be addressed at some point in
the future where a number number can
actually deal with the indexing part but
just keep that in the back of your mind
ok so results again i'm looking for
correct code and i'll do some time it's
over here and we can see that python is
painfully slow the size on
implementation is pretty fast like under
a millisecond the number of
implementation is also very fast this
implementation actually is what we're
using pandas and you say oh it's really
slow the answer is this is actually
doing a lot more work
then the siphoning position I wrote up
here it's doing things like nan checking
very important thing but for the in for
the example I use that I didn't put it
in here all right okay next slide so
we've discussed how to make pandas fast
now we'll discuss how to make pin is
slow in other words these are things you
should not do so don't use apply unless
you really really really have to this is
evidenced this was a quote somebody gave
me if you think you need to use apply
think again and then think again about
it and then okay if you really really
really need to use it great but it was
put there i think for convenience turns
out to be convenient but not performance
so you going to be really cognizant of
this app i see all the time people are
reaching for apply apply is the last
tool usually for not the first tool okay
so second second thing okay i need to
iterate because i don't know how to make
a vectorized algorithm okay so i'll use
it or tuples it arose avoid these two if
you really really need to iterate you
can use in renewables and will show that
in a couple minutes and i'll explain why
that is in the next two slots third
thing not to ever do it of updating I'll
show an example of this this is in some
sense this is a Python pattern and
however it's an anti-pattern when you
get to pandas or for numpy this actually
may work but for pandas this is
completely an anti-pattern because it's
somewhat expensive to individually index
elements and I'll show you why in a
second okay so now we're going to go
through another little notebook I have
so how to make well they're supposed to
show up slow oh well so I did a bunch of
benchmarks here and basically code is
here here's our baseline code this is a
vectorized code we're just adding one to
a series easy here's the apply code
looks simple it or tuples now the one
thing to know here is we're iterating
over eight
people so we have to index now by
position okay some sense that may be
fine it arose actually gives you a
series back and this is the reason it's
actually in this case actually it
doesn't it gives you I'm sorry it does
give you're serious this has two bad
properties and this is why it Rose is
slow one it has to consolidate the
entire d type of that row now in this
case that's cheap because it's actually
a float the entire all your details are
floats if you have non floats notes
becomes extremely expensive to do okay
here's another example this is indexing
so I'm using an indexing operator I lock
or lock or IX to actually set values in
place looks like okay Python code button
pandas this becomes painfully slow even
worse is i'm indexing and then i'm
creating something at the end again i'm
going to assert that all these results
are true they're equal to each other our
baseline is quite fast it or triples is
not bad actually apply becomes painful
more painful really painful and a lot
more painful so here's the little graph
of that and i was going to do this
original log scale but looks like so the
answer is if you're doing anything but
vectorization you shouldn't be if you
need to do something a calculation that
is very hard to vectorize then you need
to reach for another tool reach forsyth
on or reach for a number and hook it in
that's the way to make pants fast okay
i'm going to show one more notebook I I
was talking about before people like to
compare a numpy and pandas for indexing
and this is a mistake and I'll show you
why so here's a bunch of different
indexes operations all we're doing is
setting a single element we're using IX
lock and I lock will use also using a
tan diet which are specially made for
this type of single element updating
enum pie were directly updating the
value so you can see that I lock IX and
lock are you know the same order of
magnitude here at and I at are
significantly faster and numpy is faster
still okay great does this matter I had
somebody argue with me about this like
oh this you know two microseconds
actually makes a difference I'm like
well do this example here where we're
going to we're going to iteratively
update an umpire ray we're gonna do the
same thing with a data frame and then
we're going to do a vectorized indexing
operation so okay dump is pretty fast
using you know it's pretty slow actually
but it doesn't matter if you can
vectorize your population or vectorize
your index setting method so yes this
might matter to you but if you're doing
it this way I would just say go right to
cyclone and go right to non go if you if
you do need to do that and there are
cases we do need to do that okay next
okay dot values so this is a
double-edged sword like nice graphically
I explained before that you could get so
you can actually access your numpy ray
directly from pandas you can take your
series and do dat values you get an
umpire right back great you can also do
this with a data frame however the data
from this is a big problem actually
because what it will do it'll course all
your D types to a common d type and if
it's like instant floats that's okay
still might be fine however if you have
strings in there which we all have
strings in there this is a big problem
makes everything object d-type I'm
running out of time so I'm gonna hurry
up here so the point is dot values can
be great if you want to directly access
say a series if you want to access the
entire data frame and you have strings
it's a problem object e-type is there to
satisfy the need of everybody to because
they want to have objects but if you
want perform Akkad you need to avoid
them okay
alright going to okay fine okay so I'm
going to go over some do's and don'ts so
Jews have the correct d types this means
don't use object if you don't absolutely
have to and we'll discuss strings in a
min again but my point is don't
represent floats as object that there is
no reason to don't put actual objects in
a data frame where series you don't need
to and if you really do you're doing the
wrong way use PD concat so this is the
way to it's very similar to MP konica
concatenate basically I mentioned before
that there is a if you want to do lots
of insertions again you're doing it the
wrong way instead what you want to do is
construct sub data frame say concat boom
one copy all together it's easy I don't
really have too many examples of these
but I will for these particular things
categoricals use them and I will again
I'm going to defer this just a second
use the idioms and built-ins we already
talked about that apply is actually ok
in certain cases in other words if
you're applying across columns you have
some cool function that works on a
vectorized input a 1d array and I just
want to apply it across my columns okay
that's that's perfectly okay it's a nice
idiom actually okay here are the don'ts
repeated assertions we just talked about
this this can anything that can cause
repeated copies is a problem don't
repeat it inserts don't like more
optimized in other words don't try to
set elements individually in a data
frame if you have a few to set great if
you have a lot of set don't there are
various methods of updating if you have
lots of these don't try to loop over
things and do that so don't use loops
don't reinvent the wheel we already
talked about apply apply map is a
similar concept it's a again a
convenience feature that is in effect
sort of like a you funk type mechanism
where you can do something to every
single element in your data frame we
have you phones with that however apply
map is I just originally was conceived I
think as a
just a convenience feature for that so
this is a hard one actually nested group
group i apply so group I is fine apply
is fine and then I've seen a lot of code
where people actually nest them inside
the apply or do some complicated
function so as we saw with the
unwrapping group by its can be it can
work you can certainly do whatever you
want that the problem is a lot of things
are just simply not performant if you
continually do functions inside apply so
you try to want to minimize the number
of function calls you're doing or that
the complicated pneus of that function
so hence don't nest group I applies and
i'll suggest i don't have an example
here say you were doing this what you
want to do and say you're grouping by
things and then in each group you want
to do some op you want to do another
group by that is just a multi group by
so there's a diverse ways the pulley
sends out a few versions back in place
was added and in my opinions mistake but
if it was added in place doesn't help
you everybody thinks it does but it
really doesn't in very there's very
small subset of cases actually well in
general in place is implemented so this
is an operation you know almost all the
operations have an option in place
equals its defaults to false but people
said if the troons like oh this is this
is grades can make it faster no it
doesn't in fact all that it happens for
most these operations we do the
operation on copy and then shove it in
there and you get back the original
object back it doesn't actually help and
in my opinion the reason real the real
reason not to use it is it just makes
your code doesn't it doesn't look as but
you can't change things you can't
pipeline think so in my opinion there's
never a reason to use in place there
just isn't okay alright so now we're
going to my memory for a couple of
slides here i will never to hurry up
here okay these slides are by the way
are all available here and with the
notebook so you can obviously with them
so very common things to do data
conversions here's an example of i have
some may be a weird string format of
some dates i have in year month in this
case i just created it here
this doesn't annoy doesn't scroll
properly okay well whatever so three
methods of actually parsing this type of
string here's the method I've seen this
a lot again this is doing a vectorized
function your iteratively applying a
vectorized function okay that's called
the slow way the regular way is simply
to put it in with a format however
actually Ian made this point if you can
convert your strengths to ISO 8601 you
can get massive speed ups this is
implemented see the parsing of these
even some non iso 8601 strings can be
parsed but for the most part if you can
coerce yourselves to a reasonable date
format you can get massive speed ups in
the parsing okay and we can see here
slowly faster and even faster okay so my
point is that passing format essentially
is a reggaeton sparser however some of
these formats can be or have speed ups
implicit in them okay and I'll show this
in the next example as well read CSV use
it full stop okay but you come into a
lot of cases where you also have dates
and this this is a you have weird date
for me here i just created this one okay
but and people say okay used a parser
there are times used a parser limit them
generally this is also done in Python
space so it's generally not a fantastic
idea this existed this next way of doing
this is I'll call regular parsing where
you just give your you say hey parse
this column this works fantastically of
8601 strings if you don't you'll be
surprised it's how slow it is however
there's a new keyword that was
introduced conferred a temp format for a
lot of pretty common formats this
provides automatic inference of your
formats caching of them so we if you
have all the dates which of similar
formats this is per column it'll be
provided I speed ups and the last thing
is the last example here is in general
actually defer
dates date processing has a post
processing step I will just simply read
in my date with strings and then I will
process them afterwards and the reason
for this is I have a little bit more
flexibility here I can do various
operations maybe I need to do a
substitution or something I might want
to do it in a use some of the string
operations to make them very performant
because they are very performant maybe
after some to get some weird character
out of that or something and then I will
process them so i oftentimes deferred a
process to up to a step after i actually
reduce ESPN so here's the examples for
these and they're not terribly different
in this case but date parsing I actually
wanted to make it works but it actually
would turn out ok in this case and and
you know it's a simple loop but it was
fine in this case is you see regular
parsing is just painfully slow you know
it's because it's using reg axes
internally even though it's insight on
it's still using right axis so these can
be slow all right next slide right here
categoricals so these are just
introduced in version 15 and these are
an awesome feature in effect what is a
categorical categorical is a mapping of
something usually strengthened doesn't
have to be two integers okay and then we
keep a map of what these images
represent for duplicated data these are
fantastic they have two amazing benefits
one storage space they kick much less to
store and two they get you out of object
land they make your manipulations be on
integers this is fantastic so use them
so here's a quick example I'll create
the very is it a crate so you just you
have strings we created a string object
and we're just we're just as type into
category this is a I'll call it a pseudo
numpy d-type here's example so memory
usage of the object you know say oh
that's not too hard but this is reality
is not even your real num real member
usage this is actually your real memory
number usage because if we're going to
do this in Python land okay in numpy
your real memory usage is here okay
because what does an object where
operators just simply a pointer take
8bit or eight bytes and to some memory
space where it's keeping it okay so
Python using strings is bad it just
takes a lot of overhead per string
nobody is better because all it does is
that actually it keeps it as a fixed
memory block so it's actually not
terribly inefficient however once we go
to categoricals we can reduce your
memory as it's dramatically so example
for this example here all we have to do
is store this actually only stores in in
28 for the column and then 40 bytes or
whatever for the actual strings
themselves so this will have tremendous
savings on your in memory usage and
you're on disk uses and that's what
we're to show now so I right things to
hdf5 a lot we implemented this also you
can actually store so this is storing as
a fixed length string storing the
strings and this is storing with the
categoricals so you get a quite nice
savings there okay next slide here okay
next thing I always suggest to use our
iterators whenever you want to read from
say disk in it is csv or hdf5 format you
can do this with other data types as
well other formats as well you should
use iterators why it guarantees you a
constant memory usage you'll only use a
certain block of memory you have a data
frame that you can use you can do
whatever operation as you want and
that's a good thing okay yes i know i
just am refinishing five minutes all
four questions afterwards okay the other
thing i was wanted to put in is use used
columns so this is a fantastic way to
read a very wide CSV as in a table this
is very efficient when it's reading a
small number of columns that's that's a
good thing interestingly enough with
hdf5 this actually is not as easy to do
because it's a row oriented format and
selecting our columns is actually hard
so you'd be surprised the memory is this
people have been surprised is the same
okay as if you're selecting the entire
row it's just an unfortunate
problem in hdf5 you can actually select
that a single column very officially
this is actually quite efficient but
selecting more than one is just not
supported this at this point in time all
right one more slide here ok I'm going
to skip this slide but I will just point
this you guys to various ways of
thinking about serialization and I oh
there's a couple of links i have here to
this fellow Matt Matt Rockland who
developed asked we were talking in a
second he did a nice study on the cost
of serialization of various data types
so that's on my slide as well my last
slide or last so global interpreter lock
right now it exists in pandas in version
17 it will not exist we were going to
release it in all sigh con code it
wasn't actually that hard this was
actually at the prodding of various
people because the reason you can get
nice threading speedups I never
recommend i haven't talked about
threading at all and I barely touched on
multi processes because most your data
doesn't need it if it does now you'll be
able to do it you'll be able to use
threading models and multiprocessing
models in a very nice way okay next
slide so you know everybody's like oh
out of core pandas really doesn't
support out of court this at this point
in time again I will touch on something
that does there are various ways around
this but we're not gonna talk about them
here okay so my solution right now this
is a very new open source library called
desk and it will allow you to
effectively it uses pandas internally in
fact we wrote some specific features for
this to enable threading multiprocessing
and distributed computing using pandas
and it's a very similar API okay in we
may build this actually independence
where you can actually take your
computations and defer them right out
the desk right now you can do the
opposite you can use DASCO raised to
basically give you nice panda's thumb
the frames okay that's it you guys can
contribute and this talk again is on
that on github so I don't know if I
really have time for questions but I
will be here afterwards and I'm Yours
question for sure and the inferred date
times that composer does that deal with
month month a day followed by date a
month examples you can actually pass my
know your answer is I the interest for
me I never be having fun yes I now is
basically what information format does
it deals with things like you can put
whatever separators you want between the
various fields it still has to be a
regular format though any other
questions these are regular phone right
yeah oh sorry I'm sorry you can have to
question go ahead yeah you hinted bitten
out of core there I wanted to know what
are your thoughts on how blazed plays
with with pandas and sure what are what
are your suggestion there okay again
some whether those I work with they
wrote blaze so blazed plays very nice
with a pen is actually and again that's
another solution to dealing with out of
core believe just for people who don't
know base blazes basically if you think
about it it's a way to construct in
Python I'll easily evaluated expression
and then you can send it to a
computation back end one of which could
be pandas okay to actually evaluate but
it's nice that sleazy in its operation
finish there so we have transformed over
for the speaking up Charlie